[Music]
you wake up in the morning is today
today I go to jail or today the day I
get killed I've died for you is you're a
citizen
you should ain't dying for a gangster
you prefer Donnie Brasco his life or Joe
Pistone's life if you've never seen the
movie Donnie Brasco Donnie Brasco is a
story of an undercover FBI agent who
goes undercover not for six months not
for 12 months for six years and
eventually takes down two out of the
five Italian Mafia families in New York
and so when I heard about the story I
watch this movie back in 1997 when it
first came out starring Johnny Depp and
Pacino it's a phenomenal story I said I
want to sit down with the real Donnie
Brasco to find out about the true story
of what happened not just the movie and
today we are sitting with the one and
only Joe Pistone just to meet you
pleasure meeting you my pleasure it's
good to sit down with you and see it
from your perspective because you've
actually lived it's interesting you've
lived the life of a mobster and you've
been the FBI at the same time so to be
different story that we can get from it
but having said that Joe this is a
question for you you grew up somebody
who went to school you're in East Coast
you go to school and you do your part
you become a schoolteacher you're a guy
that's in school teacher you're teaching
kids you're being a regular citizen and
all of a sudden you become an FBI agent
so did you wake up one day you saw a kid
that was a troublemaker and you said you
know what this kids really starting to
piss me off I want to be an FBI agent
like what was the inspiration for you to
become an FBI agent I always wanted to
go into law enforcement but I also knew
that I wanted to get a college education
I took a job as a schoolteacher I was
waiting for an appointment into naval
intelligence
I went into naval intelligence for a
couple years and then I for filled the
not regularly read was a prerequisite
into it to get into the FBI now will you
married at that time I already had kids
I was married and I had three children
at the time actually Irizarry little
yeah fulfill my dream of going into law
enforcement Joe let me ask you growing
up I'm your Sicilian you're from a
Sicilian family yes Italian family so
you know when you think about Sicily I
mean it is Sicily right so when you were
growing up Rudy Guiliani once said that
his father told him the following quote
he says my father told me that these
mobsters you got to take them down
because a real man fights one-on-one but
these mobsters never fight one-on-one so
to him somebody put that inspiration
into him to go take down all the crime
that was taking place in New York and
that was kind of his aspiration right I
mean that's how Rudy made a name for
himself as a kid growing up did you grow
up sitting there with your dad and your
mom and your family did you watch movies
like that that you have a level of
admiration for mobsters or mother was
that ever something that you grow
because you know there's a lot of things
that we watch ourselves as kids was that
you growing up or that was not even part
of the conversation on the dialogue and
the family I grew up obviously in an
all-italian
neighborhood and in the neighborhood
where mobsters from my my father and
moms perspective is you stay away from
these guys you just keep your mouth shut
and listen and don't get involved with
them and I think that helped me later on
knowing the Italian culture growing up
Italian but knowing the mob culture a
little bit from growing up in that type
of neighborhood because there were
social clubs you know there were a
couple social clubs in my neighborhood
that the gangsters hang out hung out in
you see these guys driving flashy cars
they don't work they got money you know
and they're good to the people in the
neighborhood you know they throw the
kids in the neighborhood a couple bucks
buy him ice cream etc but what you don't
see is what goes on behind those closed
doors of the social club you know you
don't know about the the murders and the
extortions and everything else that
takes place so I think that that's the
attraction that the public sees about
about the mob you're now you know about
to be recruited and you do a couple
things I think you know at one point you
were undercover that you were doing
mainly was it gambling and prostitution
you were finding that was the main
specialty that you had and then all of
us and they asked you to
do this work of you going undercover
explained that transition on how that
happened when I join the FBI
I had my years in naval intelligence
they noted that I had the street smart
to conduct investigations so I would go
in on gambling dens and work the
gambling cases work prostitution cases
buy stolen commodities you know like art
stocks bonds now you are undercover
while you're doing these or no yeah yeah
on a on a case by case basis and how
long would the last 30 60 90 days type
of deal well it could be it could be a
week two weeks three weeks
Oh leap ensign how much activity you had
with the bad guy on how long it took you
to gain two bad guys confidence and make
the exchange and buy the commodity were
these bad guys Italians or no they were
not Italians no these bad guys were not
strictly Italians they were just just
thieves that's interesting how they're
not connected because you go down many
years and not one of these bad guys
recognizes you from a prior case that
you got him okay so who called you and
they said Joe because you know J Edgar
Hoover was not a fan of it because he
believed that if you want to became an
undercover you know you're gonna turn
and go the other side so he wasn't a fan
of it until you know you came around you
kind of proved him wrong but when was it
when they kelmot came up to NSA Joe this
is the project we have this is what we
want you to kind of walk us through how
that took place prior to joining FBI I
had worked as a truck driver during my
years in college and in the summer times
I drove 48 footers big rigs so I had
that experience and there was an
operation at a Tampa that they were
still in cars and trucks and they had an
opportunity to put an undercover in it I
was one of the few guys in the bureau at
that time that could that could drive
the big rigs so I was asked if I wanted
to take on that that operation as an
undercover and I did so I was able to
infiltrate that group and worked at for
over a year and a half that was a
year-and-a-half case yeah that was a
year-and-a-half undercover operation
what we would do is a you would come to
us and say I want a Mercedes Benz
okay what color you want what kind of
interior you want what extras you want
and then we go to find a mercedes-benz
dealership and and hook it at night
that's it that's it I learned to be a
car thief Wow year and a half for here
now how'd you get did you get publicity
for that once you took those guys down
well they went to trial and we got all
the convictions so what were you aware
it was the Joe Pistone named public yet
or not yet yeah yeah it was yeah see
that's the part that's that's
fascinating to me on how this happen
because we had the trials in Tampa so
sure but when they do recognition and
you know they recognize an FBI agent for
the work they do they don't typically do
it publicly they do that while they
function would surely it wasn't
advertised it was just whatever the
court room was go test you know the
court testimony didn't have anything to
do with New York so maybe there's not a
okay so after that is that kind of how
you earned your stripes and they said
look this guy can hang he's pretty calm
he can go in and make it work why don't
we give him this project and when they
did were there other options they were
looking at or were there like a
processor it was just a meeting and say
Joe this is you we've decided you're
gonna do this work well actually I get
back to New York after that
year-and-a-half operation my supervisor
by the name of gentleman by name a guy
Murata
had this idea for this undercover
operation he asked me if I wanted to be
the undercover you know because of my
background being Italian he it was
geared toward the Mafia
the Italians I said sure and I actually
speak Italian by the way not that great
at that time yeah but not that you know
I mean you lose everything you know got
it but I'll tell you what you didn't
have to because a lot of these guys
don't speak it and the guys back at home
too but yeah back at all it took about
three to four months planning the
operation getting everything in place
what does that mean planning the
operation the FBI doesn't shotgun
undercover operations you got to have
specific targets you got to have a
specific plan of operation so by the
time we did that then you have to you
have to build yourself a legend because
why do these guys want me you know or
why what would attract them so you have
to have a you have to have a legend
since it was going to be a deep-cover
operation
you had to get it have everything in
place before you actually went out onto
the streets
you can't pick a profession that's a
profession involving violence because
what does that mean well as a in other
words I couldn't I couldn't say I
couldn't go in and say hey I'm a
leg-breaker
you know I'm a money collector I'm a
I'm a stick-up man got it there had to
be a special skill like yours was being
a jewelry will know how to kind of I
know see him as an undercover agent you
can't commit acts of violence so if I go
in and say hey you know I'm a stick-up
man well they're gonna expect me to go
just do that - a bank robbery with a gun
and and and actually you can't do that
so we figured the best criminal
profession would be a jewel thief for
various reasons it's not one of violence
a lot of jewel thieves operate alone I
could get jeweled and precious gems from
the government to show that I went out
and did a score now you take a step
further if I say I'm a jewel thief I
better know about diamonds and pressures
you know how did that happen because you
knew when you said this is a fur gaze
you know this is a how did how did you
learn that I went to I went to school to
learn about diamonds and precious gems
like a private non FBI nothing related
after the FBI just went and enrolled and
I mean you got the I could be able to
tell the divorce or corneum and like a
diamond and then we had a we had a
friendly jeweler that I spent time in
his back room with his diamond guy and
then once I once I became comfortable
that you know I could at least discuss
diamonds and precious gems then it was
time to hit the streets and you read the
the book Donnie Brasco you know you hear
the story the background everything but
this theme starts with the bar Masoli
so how does here with lefty and by the
way you here had Mira introduced you to
lefty you read all these different
things so and you know Tony Mira's got a
whole different reputation of himself
you're right so who actually did
introduce you like did he did Mira tell
you go to this bar did you get connected
with him for us before left he came walk
us through that a little bit
we had several bars and restaurants
targeted that we knew that these
individuals hung out in and the idea was
for me to visit these bars and
restaurants get my face seen
hopefully get into conversation with
people because you don't walk into a
mafia place and say hey you know I'm
Donnie Brasco jewel thief
I like to start doing business with you
know yeah who do you know and the idea
was hopefully getting conversation and
go from there so that's what I did and
it had to be a seven day a week job
because you can't be around Monday to
Friday because once you know once they
they recognize your face if you're never
around Saturdays and Sundays you see
what I'm saying so you can't have the
same routine over so can't be every day
at 9:00 o'clock in the morning or it is
talking exactly so you got it you got to
make sure you're changing that up yeah
exactly
and while you're doing this are you
living with your wife and kids or no no
I'm living in my own apartment my wife
and kids are across the country so
initially the project wasn't supposed to
go for six years six months six months
was the plan yeah so it gets started
okay in the introduction Mira lefty how
does that go my first introduction was
with the Colombo family out of New York
City I met them I got friendly with a
bartender at one of the places after
about maybe six months he finally you
know we finally connected as far as
talking one night he brings me to an
all-night crap game and it's you know
all mob guys and he doesn't introduce me
to anybody but I'm with him so I'm good
I see mirror at these games through
conversation everything he knows hey
this guy's a street guy he knows what's
going on so he introduces me to guys and
I had some diamonds one day I go in I
come into the bar one night and I say I
got a package here then I need X amount
of money for I don't tell him what what
it is this is to the bartender about
okay if you can do anything let me know
he just takes it about two weeks later
and during this two-week period I don't
ask him about the package and he don't
say anything but two weeks later he says
hey Donnie said somebody left this
envelope for you okay and it's he had so
sold the Diamonds the bartender's are 10
okay so now when we go out and go to the
crap games now he introduces me as Don
the jeweler because I gave them so now
you have a reputation now I got a record
how long since you started going to the
bar until that happens because this
takes patient six months six months
until you're even introduced in yeah oh
my gosh a lot of so six months you just
got to keep being patient every day and
not even just out there every night
hoping that open to gain a conversation
with someone okay so six months later
you get you get you get to meet these
guys he calls you down to jeweler yeah
then he introduced me a guy by name a
Jilly Jilly it was a Columbo Jilly has a
place out in Brooklyn so you know Julie
says me one day Donnie wants you you
know much come out tomorrow you know
come out to my my place in Brooklyn his
club in Brooklyn I was ok Jilly so I go
out there and he had to do you know
since the bartender vouch for me i Gilly
introduces me to to his crew I'm out
there maybe a couple months with them
they were very active crew and hijacking
and other activities now made guy is
somebody that's been officially inducted
into a Mafia family ok there are a lot
of rules that the Mafia has it's very
important if you're an undercover you
know what these rules are because
they'll help you ingratiate yourself and
they'll also keep you alive when you
work undercover you have to know your
enemy you gotta know everything about
your enemy because if you don't you're
gonna get killed so I knew the rules you
never embarrassed a made guy in front of
anybody else if I'm in an argument with
you and I'm not a made guy if I
embarrass you in front of anybody else
I'm in trouble
the other rule is during the course of
this verbal argument you and I have if
you give me a slap and I hit you back
you're gonna get killed - a made guy - a
made guy
in any undercover operation where you
infiltrate an organized crime group that
you know has violence attached to him
you're gonna get into argument because
everybody doesn't like everybody I mean
you know course it's not a kumbaya world
sure you know these guys get out of jail
and one of them's a made guy and one of
them isn't this is Colombo family is the
Colombo's time
Frankie and Patsy they had some scores
lined up so chilli tells me and I said
whatever the scores were it's too
dangerous you want to rob a factory in
in broad daylight it's a crazy idea one
day I come to the club and Julie says
Donny said let's walk and talk
now walk and talk as you walk down the
street and you talk and the reason they
do that is because I don't think
anybody's listening Patsy was the main
guy he said Patsy wants to have a
sit-down so I said well let's have a
sit-down
so we going back at Julie's club they
locked the door we should down at a
table
Patsy takes out his gun out of the thing
it lays on a table and he said Donny if
you don't tell me and convinced me that
you're as good as thief as Jilly says
you are the only way you're going out of
here is rolled up in that rug I said
what do you need to know so that's
another thing too you never give anybody
up so he wants and you know he's asking
me about what you said you're from Miami
tell me some guys in Miami that you
thieved with I'm not telling you anybody
I'm not giving you names and guy says
look you just got out of jail how do I
know you to become an informant in jail
no I'm you're telling them this I'm
telling it but you know I'm on a fine
line here right we go back and forth
back and forth so after about five hours
finally Jilly says hey look it's over
Donnie's been around us for like three
months nothing's ever happened this is
over now I got a another problem they
just called Donny out why isn't he
ticked off if I apologize they're all
gonna say they just called Donny yeah
how come he's not Pio now I can't do
anything to patsy because he's a made
guy that's what I'm thinking because he
just said that the two rules but
Frankie's Frankie's wit passes so as we
get up I lay Frankie out right there
right there Patsy starts on me but I
can't do anything but just defend myself
against them but I just keep hitting
hitting Frankie so finally they break it
up but right now I know I got to get
away from these guys so after they break
it up I'd say Jilly you know no
disrespect to you but I can't be around
these guys
anymore I can't be around Patsy and
Frank anymore because this is not over
with them so he says well I understand
now I had met Tony mirror at the games
mm-hmm the crap game at the crab yes I
leave the Colombo's the next time I go
to the crafts games I sign up to mirror
because I know he's a Bonanno guy and
he's down in downtown in Little Italy I
start hanging with Tony Mirra but he's
he's off the charts I mean the guy was a
definitely cycle I mean even if the
wiseguys really didn't like him but he
was a big moneymaker it was an earner
he was a big earner in the job trade for
the bonanno's and he had just gotten out
of jail but I started hanging out with
him and he introduced me to Lefty
because they were all in the same crew
down in Little Italy and I got into a
couple beefs with mirror now he's a made
guy oh yes oh so you and he's a guy
that's got a reputation that I I heard
he's killed more people than cancer when
you read about this guy but one night
we're in a we're in a restaurant and
it's like three four o'clock in the
morning and he starts berating the
waitress I said Tony I said you know I
said it's not her fault leave her alone
well he went eight he he start calling
me and there's other people there
he just berated me for telling calling
him out yeah but he doesn't hit she
doesn't fight no no no I can't let him
think that he's gonna be talking to me
like this all the time the next day he
and I are loaning and I just told my
said Tony I said look there's nobody
around now but don't ever talk to me
like that again you told him that
yeah what was his reaction his reaction
was like he was stunned I said because
if you do I said you better watch your
back
I said cuz I'll come after you when
nobody is around he told him that yeah
how's this reaction even after you say
well his reaction was you know you can't
talk to me like that I said I'm talking
to you because there's nobody else
around
so it's mmm so at least give him the
respect to save face by doing a private
yeah but I couldn't show him that I was
gonna take his did he do you think he
appreciated that are you at least to the
price thing he did okay well you know
that's what these guys that service
ribbon
that's what they respect they don't
respect weakness you know it's like a
terrorist terrorist doesn't respect you
when you're weak I had to let him know
that I wasn't gonna take it I may have
to take his verbal abuse around other
people but I was gonna let him know
later on this doesn't fly with you where
are you know how far into it is it from
the moment you decided it goes like this
as you said six months you were at the
bar but how many how long have you been
in now almost a year almost a year to
getting to this point yeah but let me
ask you were you Mira's guy where Mira
hasn't locked you and as his guy don't
know that he hasn't done that was his
problem he you are or you're not yeah I
got it so he can't say you're his
product like somebody else can the rule
is a made guy bring somebody else in he
goes to his captain and says I'm
claiming Donny Mira never did that
why didn't he thought who knows who
knows interesting well good for you that
he yeah it was the best yeah he goes
away to the can again now is when I
marry up with lefty okay now at that
time our captain was a guy by name of
Mike said Bella because Gallente was
still alive in the boss hmm now lefty
goes to Mike and says I'm claiming
Donnie and Mike's the cap so he can do
that Mike's the captain that he was
lefties captain God so now I'm under
Mike Sabella when they're lefty got it
so that's so that's how the relationship
we left it begins okay so now you meet
lefty now lefty and mirror couldn't be
you know more opposite and personalities
on the way they were with you what was
unique about lefty in your relationship
with him mirror you could never get
close to mirror what's that with most of
them or no was it just how Mira was I
was just mirror most people didn't like
mirror not yet though yeah lefty hated
everybody I mean be honest with you most
guys hated him because he had no respect
for anybody women girls none at all
here's prale yeah but he makes so much
money yeah so lefties so now you mean so
I was a best man at his wedding and I
met his I met his daughters you
and I used to go to his house part of my
legend while I was an orphan okay so I
had no family but real life you're not
real life no yeah but Imbaba were you
close to your father yourself yeah sure
very good relation no issues with father
at all got it so your your legend is
you're an orphan and I remember that
part when your father was in the
military and he got shot by the Japs and
that's the scene in the bath that I'm
gonna do like I'm not taking off my
shoes so it's okay so you say this to
Lefty you know I would go to Lefty's
house for dinner on Sunday in that world
Sunday if you go there that's family
you're not yeah it's like a pinnacle
yeah yeah so now at what point was it
when you and left to get really close
past that war it's like I know you're
going Sunday's and it's family
when was it when the first time he told
you says listen I have your back you're
my guy I love you we're gonna do this
together we're gonna take over the world
together
when was that lefty was running running
booked for the underboss of the Bonanno
family he brings me in and of course he
introduces me to Nicky Baron jello who
was the underboss Nicky is not Nicky
mouth that's a different Magee right you
tell me the complete different Nick in
the classic Nicki Marron jello he got
the underboss of the bonanno's so lefty
brings me to - Nicky says Donny's gonna
be working with me in the operation now
it's it's maybe four months or somethin
you know these guys see me every day I'm
talking to them you know having dinner
with them or lunch whatever the FBI had
another undercover operation going out
in Milwaukee simultaneously yeah so this
is the one that they said we want you to
kind of help the other guys out exactly
my whole mindset in undercover is only
one person saves your life and that's
you the undercover SEAL Team six HRT
they could be on the other side of that
door
but by the time you shoot me it's what
action versus reaction the action is you
shoot me the reaction is them coming
through the door you see what I'm saying
not that they're not doing they're here
wins
action wins that's exactly all right
action window so my whole mindset was I
my own life every undercover has to look
out for their own security hmm
don't depend on somebody else right so
my first question is who's the
undercover so I know the undercover in
fact I had worked the undercover that
was in Milwaukee I had worked with him
before
so you have this Milwaukee of you I know
I know the undercover I say sure but I
gotta talk to Tony that was his
undercover name I gotta talk to Tony so
me and Tony meet he tells me about the
operation Exeter Exeter I can't just go
to lefty because I got to go to lefty
first I can't just go to left and say
hey lefty I know a guy out and out in
Milwaukee's got a great business we
ought to go do because I got a distance
again you know I got to distance myself
if anything happens I just bring up in a
conversation he left G I got a call out
of the blue from this this guy that I
knew from 10 years ago guy was a great
thief he doesn't do any reaction mm-hmm
I let maybe a week go by and then I
bring the same conversation up and
finally says what's this guy do I says
he's trying to start a vending machine
business the first thing he says is he F
and crazy they'll blow him up out there
he says you can't just start a defend
the machine business he said that's
control what's this guy got so I said
well he tells me he's got a he's got
trucks he's got vending machines he's
got officer guy Milwaukee's still yeah
yeah so now it piques his interest
because what is it about it's about mr.
Benjamin you know so one day he says to
me a said though tell like God to fly in
here and I want to talk to him it's okay
les Tony was a great agent I mean he was
a former Marine just a tough tough guy
that evening me and Lefty go to the
restaurant and Tony comes I'm in the
middle of Tony and and lefty right it's
just the three of you no one else is
ever sent the bar got it so now his mind
said is if he doesn't talk directly to
Tony whatever is said it's not illegal
there's no conspiracy
all night the conversation is like
Donnie tell Tony whatever the question
was tell Tony what did what business is
he in out there Tony tells me I Lefty
this is the businesses in Donnie tell
Tony how many machines he has you know
it goes back and forth now the next day
we go see Mike Sabella because we can't
do anything without the captain and we
explained to Mike Sabella exactly what
you know what's going on so he says ok
you two guys fly out there don't talk to
anybody just see if he has a business
going
so me and Lefty fighting Milwaukee meet
Tony he takes us to the offices he shows
us he has a warehouse full of machines
he's got a couple trucks the whole thing
in the mob one family cannot go into
another family's territory and conduct
business you have to get their
permission and then do you give them 20
points or ten points or sever they want
whatever they want yeah we got it
now sit down with our consigliere the
Bonanno family consigliere right so we
explained to to Bobby his name was Bobby
at the time now we have to lie not to
Bobby but we got Ally to Chicago because
Bobby has to go to Chicago tell them
about our operation Chicago then tells
Milwaukee and then Milwaukee decides all
right have them come out and sit down
with us we have to tell Chicago that
Tony the undercover has been with the
bonanno's for ten years if we tell them
that the bonanno's just met Tony through
me that seems to be common though you
you read a lot about that where Capone
used to do that Capone will meet a guy
from a swap meet and he would say this
guy's my guy's been with me for a while
and he just met him a weaker if I'm
sorry God he would say that God he would
say because otherwise otherwise they
would say hey you just met this guy why
are you doing he's with us he's in
Milwaukee it's not even a doubt part
it's who's gonna make the money part six
right out of interesting right so we fly
out there being a lefty when we get the
call be at this restaurant so we left
the Youth Tony go to the restaurant and
there's the boss of the family
Frank Bella story his underboss his two
sons and one of his captains and we have
a dinner we tell him you know exactly
what we want because he controls all the
vending in Milwaukee and all the towns
around it right so we'd be infringing on
his the agreement was Tony would do all
the work they would give him stops that
he can put the machines in that they
didn't have their machines in out of
that business the bananas would have to
give the balusters Ares I forget what
the percentage was a percentage of
profit was it one of the first victories
where you're like wow we just got these
guys now we have we know we got the
family here in Milwaukee and Chicago
weekend well the bonanno's thought
enough of me and trusted me enough to
bring them out there now here's another
thing that's lost and we just married
two FBI families to conduct business
together
never happened before Wow all right so
Joe this entire time how are you staying
cool like you know what is your thought
pattern for you I mean look let me in
sports players get paid tens of millions
of dollars every year to stay cool when
they're taking a last shot with two
seconds left and their life's not on the
line like the coach is not saying hey MJ
you don't make the shot we don't kill
you but with you you slip one slip in
your life is on the line so what are you
doing to make sure you stay cool
throughout this entire time that goes
back to the individual you never change
your personality in the undercover
business you always stay never change
your personality like DNA the way your
wire is exactly right you're not so okay
got it
all right so in other words I can't have
a preconceived notion that all mobsters
you know or tough guys and drinking
because I don't drink I've never been a
drinker and my thought process and
mindset and undercover is I don't change
what I would do normally you and you're
in this role for six years and you've
never been a mobster before it's not
like you did it for a day or two or five
minutes or an hour or drive how do you
go for six years I mean if you go for
six years a part of me is curious to
know did you at one point actually
forget about the fact that you're an FBI
agent and you became a mobster or was
alike you're living a double life like a
man who's married to two different wives
and neither one of them knows about the
other wife I never lost the fact that
that I was an FBI a never Joe Pistone no
to me all my undercover roles were just
another investigation and you never got
emotionally attached no never no did I
did I liked like lefty or like Sonny
there were certain traits about the guys
that I did but I never got emotionally
attached enough to them that oh man you
know this guy's going to go to jail or
this guy's going to get killed
because long-term deep undercover
everybody can't do it's a special
personality and a special mental
toughness that the guys that do deep
cover and long-term can do was there a
moment where you were so into deep and I
know you wanted to be a made guy because
you were upset when they took you out
because you wanted to be made guy was it
you wanted to be a made guy because of a
self recognition competitive side of you
or because of pride that I went in and I
made it all the way up to being a made
guy or that the hit was going to be
bigger if you were made got to be able
to say look I infiltrated and I got all
the way up to Vienna mate guy which one
was it for you we got six years invested
in this it's a long time okay nobody in
the undercover field has ever gotten
this close to the Mafia where I was
going to be a made guy in four months
why not wait out the four months and let
me get made for what the what was your
motivation the motivation was is that
look at the kick in the arse to the
Mafia
they made an FBI agent because remember
above it is time the Mafia was like an
invincible entity to the American public
and he do they won they had an
undercover agent at the top echelon of
the families putting different families
together but they also made him you see
the bad publicity and and do you prefer
Donnie Brasco his life or Joe Pistone's
life Joe Pistone's life hands down hands
down now let me ask you let me restate a
question Joe Pistone is not married he
doesn't have three kids okay
and Joe becomes a FBI agent do you
prefer Joe Pistone's life or Donnie
Brasco is life Joe Pistone still so you
have no s there was no part of it where
you got so deep where you're like my
gosh this life is fascinating to me you
truly wanted to take these guys down
yeah because that was my job I was my
job I understand the job part so it
might be hard to be but you only explain
to why and here's how I'm processing
this say I'm married but let's just say
I'm you know John Doe and I'm married to
a girl named Mary okay and I love Mary
okay and I work with the scroll and Mary
works at Sears and I work at IBM and I
start getting really close to this girl
and maybe I'm starting to spend a lot of
time with her and me and Mary are gone
through issues and this girl here is
treating me really good and it happens 1
month 2 months 3 months 6 months 12
months 18 months she's cried we've cried
we've had moments nothing's yet happened
okay emotionally I'm getting a little
too deep with this relationship here
right emotionally if you think about it
there was never that moment for you
where emotionally you didn't go on to
the other side where feeling never Wow
so so then that says a lot about your
mental and emotional toughness to be
able to process it that way and never
get in too deep because you were
able to convince a lefty that you were
the person he loved
yeah and Sonny black too so maybe you
need to go play poker these poker
tornensis you got the glasses on already
so you look like you're ready to play
poker and crush everybody and my outlook
is look everybody has a choice in life
you chose to be a gangster I chose to be
an FBI agent so if you want to be a
gangster Kobe go big I chose to be an
FBI agent and as an FBI agent my job is
if we know you are breaking the law to
gather evidence of you breaking the law
it almost is like you have to be
emotional Asst while you're going
through this because while you're doing
is six years away from your wife and
kids you come in and scene I mean these
are peak of your kids they're grown-up
they're going through that they want
daddy to be around recitals being missed
all these other things being missed
arguments would wife validated some of
the scenes in a movie role obviously
more Hollywood or fabricated you know
that like this slap all this other stuff
so how are you managing the personal
family side and you know what is she
doing to not get upset and lose her cool
to tell people who you really are
because there come the FBI guys are
coming to you I mean she asked to be a
mentally and emotionally tough person to
do what she did so how was that dynamic
on the under family side exactly I mean
look you can't go into an undercover
operation if your wife or your
girlfriend or if it's a girl if it's a
female undercover you know her husband
or her boyfriend or whatever if you
don't know the other person if you don't
have a partner that you know that is
also mentally tough and also has their
own character it's not gonna work
obviously obviously that's that's a
difficult task you know of course it is
how often was she seen you what we often
was it like the once every month how
often would you see family maybe once
every four five six months all depended
wait a minute I would thought you were
gonna say once every four or five days
yeah
once every four or five months unlike
for one day or like for a week at a time
I might fly in and spend the day maybe
two days I was lucky every every four
five six months fly out yeah and you're
still with your wife till today same one
Joe
you married up like at the highest level
I'm married an Irish lady I mean let me
tell you if you're watching this you Wow
marry three kids wife family you're
going through this part you've seen him
once every six months
did the fights did the heat get it get
getting higher and higher and higher
where eventually she told you said Joe
we can't do this anymore you got to cut
it was there a moment for that no not
really
there was one time when I actually
almost pulled out because she was in a
bad car accident she was yeah yeah how
long ago was that into that was maybe
three years and hint to the operetta
and that's when I thought well maybe you
know maybe I should get out we were in
in two in two three years I was really
engrossed now you know in embedded with
the bonanno's we had the operation going
in in Milwaukee so I felt if I you know
if I do get out all this work that other
people have put in done is gone so after
some real soul-searching I decided to
stay you talk to her about it or no you
just made the decision on your own that
I told it I was gonna stay you told her
you're gonna Stan yeah but she
devastated was she annoyed by was she
hurt by I think she probably was a
little hurt but you know she was in she
was on a lot of medications oh maybe she
didn't understand but no she was it did
levity help you on that levity kind of
help you go through this or was it was
it was it kind of when you were on your
own by yourself were you kind of finding
that way for you to be calm or more
relaxed or was your level of tense and
intensity going higher and higher and
higher I always stayed on a plane it's
the personality I guess so why don't we
talk about Sonny black a little bit cuz
you know I've asked a lot of you about
Sonny black and he seems like a you know
a guy with a lot of his own colorful
type of a personality so
you're coming up you're making the name
you're doing some work in Florida you're
getting things done you're building some
credit for yourself and Sonny gets
picked up and he becomes a boss and he
starts kind of seeing that's what's
happening with you and then there's this
event that takes place in Florida with
the you know you got to get this boat
you got to get a nice boat and you go
get this FBI boat and you and Sonny have
a conversation there where and I'm
covering a lot of different things but I
kind of want to hear from you where
Sonny says something like hey I think
Lefty's holding you back I think you
know I can help you become a made man
and all this other stuff how did that
transition take place from Lefty to you
starting to get closer to Sonny because
if I read it well enough I've studied it
properly you probably spend most time
with Lefty after I left he's probably
Sonny that you spend the most time with
right correct how did that transition
take place well what happened was is
that I'm with Lefty and remember Mike
Sabella was our captain and carmine
Galletti was a boss so now we're in
Little Italy they whack carmine Galante
they make a guy by name a rusty rastelli
the boss of the family who's in prison
at those in prison right Sonny black now
gets up to captain they knock Mike down
because Mike was close but carmine
Galante Nicki Marron jello was galette
these underboss they go to Mike and
Nicky mm-hmm and say look you either
step down or we're gonna whack you since
they knocked Mike down now the admit you
know that the administration of the
family they put me and Lefty under Sonny
black because he's now elevated the
captain he's in Brooklyn so now me and
Lefty have to report the Brooklyn
everyday to Sonny black so of course I
get introduced to Sonny again you know
Sonny's involved in in gambling's got
gambling operations going it's good it's
moving swag so I'm involved in all of
this all of this with them now the FBI
has another undercover operation in
Tampa they were trying to get the Santo
Trafficante who was the mafia boss in
Florida but they they weren't getting to
him
and they say hey you think he can bring
the bonanno's to Florida I brought him
out to Milwaukee I don't know you know I
don't want you know I said I tell me who
the undercover agent is I said let me
see what I can do so I'd go through the
same routine but this time what what I
do is I said I can't I can't say again
somebody called me you know it's a
Donnie you know I said what we'll do we
were going back and forth to Miami a lot
when I say we me and Lefty
all right was he like to go down there
on the weekends and hang out all right
because we had one this is not business
no for fun because we we had an in that
one of the major hotels that you know we
would get a suite and just hang out by
the pool so I said I should have the
undercover agent who also was going by
the name of Tony bump into us in the
hotel restaurant bar bump into us yeah
this way it's not like hey left you know
guy from Florida call me right so that's
what happened you know a chance meeting
okay hey Donnie how you doing I haven't
seen you blah blah blah Tony hey I want
you to be watching me lifting I got a I
got a nightclub up in Tampa their minds
are always working about how to make
money hmm right and of course a
nightclub you're thinking of yeah no
kidding you know yeah you know it got a
nice Club it's a private club watch it
guys you know come on up sometime you
know one day I said you left why don't
we take a run down and check this club
out so you know tell Sonny yeah go ahead
check it out so Mia left me a lefty
slide down and shows us around I mean
it's gorgeous
he's on like five acres it's got tennis
courts at night the place is jammed we
go back tell Sonny Sonny flies down and
now you know they get the idea oh we got
a great thing going here now we have to
go through the same routine because they
can't conduct any illegal business here
because it's traffic can't these
territory same thing
negotiate dollars with me who's been
with me for 10 years right now the whole
difference here is once they set up the
meeting with trafficante me and Sonny go
to the meeting just me and Sonny left
he's not there know which ticks him off
why wouldn't left him either Sonny
didn't want him there oh wow
Sonny didn't want about it so I'm now in
the precarious situation because he says
you know me and Bonnie are going to meet
Trafficante now it seem like there's
there's there's some animosity between
from lefty to Sonny because lefty felt
like I've been here for 30 years when am
I going to get the opportunity to kind
of get along so was that kind of deeper
oh yeah because you know he's figuring
he's bringing you in to meet with him
mm-hmm
I've been a wise guy forever I got it I
got a placate lefty you say left what's
the difference you know I'm still your
guy you know we can do this and so me
and Sonny meet with traffic canny
Trafficante gives the okay you guys can
do what you want there we get it we get
a cup we're good with it so that as long
as they get a cut of it what does he
care got it he's not putting any men
there to run anything got it then what
happens is is that the guys want to go
out on a fishing trip so the FBI has a
boat I said left do you remember we were
out in San Diego I said remember we met
those couple girls at the bar and we
bought him dinner he said yeah I said
well you know one of them told me your
brother has a boat I always backed stuff
up so I said let me see if I can find
the number so the next day I said you
know what I said yeah I got the number
here in my little address book so we set
it up and we went out and went out
fishing net cetera et cetera
well that boat was used in another FBI
undercover operation and was not
supposed to be surfaced and what
happened was there was a leak to the
media about the undercover operation so
the FBI had to surface the the operation
prematurely and the boat was on the
cover of Newsweek and on the cover of
knows yeah I thought it was a story
inside the nose week
was undercover it was undercut I'm sure
was under Co Wow I'm sure it was so so
so when that happens were you under
because you were on a flight the first
time you saw it right I so when was it
when he saw it and he found that you
were we were in Miami actually because I
remember him saying come on let's go to
wolfies in Miami I think it was a it's
famous Jewish delicatessen okay I mean
everybody knows and we go there and we
sit down and you know and he says this
looked familiar
just the two of you yeah I said it's a
boat he said we were on that boat I said
left how can we be on that boats now the
name of the boat was a left hand what
are the chances it's not only find a
boat the boat's name is left so he said
Donny what's my name
I said lefty he said what's the name in
a boat I said you do I'm gonna forget
that so I let me let me see her Wow I
said left even if it was nobody's come
after us they were after all these
politicians and he said Donny said I
don't know if I should tell you know if
I should go tell the bosses I said lefty
we're still walking around
I said look when these arrests were made
we're still walking around I said they
don't want us you know what did we do we
went on the boat we went fishing you
know had some submarine sandwiches some
heroes that's it so let me ask you is he
doubting you or is he doubting somebody
else on the crew that may have been a
informant who was he questioning you
that moment well at that moment he was
questioning to me
he was question was but don't forget now
I've been with him so long
and nothing ever was what I'm saying it
ever happened you know he was saying did
she ever say that you know I should know
she just told me her brother her brother
had a boat we ever got to go out on it
could yeah we could so then you guys go
then yeah and he never mentioned it to
anybody
none of the he never brought up to son
ever brought it up to and being never
saw it either
no so that's so interesting nobody else
nobody ever brought it up he was the
only one who brought it up
got it so so then you have the opening
to the restaurant you know the opening
of the nightclub and then the cops show
up and they have that whole scene that
takes place and then you guys go to
prison when you're in prison son a lefty
tells sunny there's a snitch here right
in that moment do you vividly remember
that moment when lovey said there's a
snitch so when he said that what
happened I'm assuming everyone's gonna
be Sunny's gonna be looking at everybody
but everybody knew everybody you know I
mean when I say everybody knew everybody
you know it was it was the wise guys you
know so then you guys come out then you
go and you're coming back and things are
starting to get kind of heated and you
know you go out there and and and and
was this the first time that you
actually saw them killing somebody right
in front you had you already seen no no
no I had never seen it what happened was
that I I really wasn't there when they
killed these guys that would that was
movie that was movie stuff but I had
gotten a contract to kill Bruno who had
didn't show up Sonny Bruno who's the
father
who'd had issues with them right
remember they killed the three camp yeah
Sonny Bruno's a cocaine guy right that
he was yeah well his name was Bruno your
own della Connie they killed his father
big trend and and feel lucky it was only
one that was there were three kapos that
opposed rusty rastelli and they were
trying to make sure they got everybody
because Bruno wanted to retaliate right
and Bruno was supposed to show up at the
meeting to get killed and it did it I
was supposed to be there and then at the
last minute they cancelled me out and
then I was supposed to being the cleanup
crew with the guys that cleaned it up
but they cancelled me out because they
had they had enough guys so they were
supposed to take you out yeah they
didn't you've got canceled yeah did you
did you I don't feel guilty about Nicky
getting killed or no was it it was it
kind of like you know not at all
hey you know like I said you made a
choice in life you know it's your choice
to be a gangster that's amazing to me
that in your money it's it's not
necessarily cut it out the way you're
making it seen that the thing is we
these guys is that you wake up in the
morning and is today today I go to jail
or today today I get killed so sunny
says to you one time the whole thing is
how strong you are right and how much
power you got and how [ __ ] mean you
are that's what makes you rise in a mob
every day is a [ __ ] struggle because
you don't know who's looking to knock
you off especially when you become a
captain or boss every day somebody is
looking to dispose of you and take your
position you always got to be on your
toes every day's a scam day to keep your
power in position suddenly told you that
yeah did he tell you this as he was
starting to get really close to you and
wanted to help you become a made man was
it at that moment when you thought yes
so you know the life Sonny and I had a
lot of a lot of one-on-one conversation
if I didn't feel like going back uptown
I would stay upstairs with him sleep on
his couch at the time he's one of the
acting bosses of the Bonanno family
did you see Samia more as a leader or
lefty with Sonny dodo was coming up out
Sonny when I today yes Sonny was a
leader was Lefty more emotional and
Sonny was more stable or ya got it
Sonny was a leader I get up in the
morning Sonny goes to cross now here's
the acting boss of the family goes
across the street to the bakery gets two
coffees hard rolls with butter and
brings him back and we're sitting on his
couch in our underwear drinking coffee
and you know hard rolling bagel with a
cartoon on a television cartoon cartoons
now that's that's straight mobster you
go chicken cartoon could you ever do
that with lefty
no because Lefty you said lefty was a 24
24/7 yeah 365 day a year gangster Sonny
had the downside Sonny was a stone-cold
gangster but but it was a little more
down-to-earth about about stuff and in
one conversation he told me she said
Donny said you know lefties holding you
back now is he feeling me out to see
where my loyalties lie if I'm gonna turn
on lefty because I'm close to him now
but if I say yeah I know I know Sonny
you know but I get
and then it's like to him well hell if
he turns on Lefty what's he gonna do
with me down the road mm-hmm so you know
I said Sonny
I've known lefty from day one he's got a
lot of faults but he's my guy I wouldn't
know you without him so he sees I got to
show him that I'm a loyal guy but I
gotta show him too
then I'm smart enough to know lefty has
false and then as time goes on we're in
a restaurant in Brooklyn called creasy's
now that there's this there's this rift
within the Bonanno family the three
captains that that want to take over the
family against Sonny join Messina and a
Sicilian faction there was a Sicilian
faction of the Bonanno family run by
South Catalano that faction was with
Sonny and Lefty and and rastelli he
tells he says Donnie said they're gonna
open the books in December in other
words they're gonna induct members he
said I already proposed you for
membership
everybody gave you a thumbs up Sonny
Sonny Sonny Stella me so you're gonna
become a made guy in December how long
is that before the operation shuts down
late May so you're seven months away
from being America yeah and we shut the
operation down in July two months later
two months later when the FBI took over
and they said no here's what we're doing
they went to a lefty and they want to
these guys because of the killings now
don't forget they kill those three guys
I get the contract to kill Bruno who who
didn't show Sonny sends me to Miami he
said we think he's in Miami so I go to
Miami
I look around Miami the deal was that if
I find him I call the FBI they come out
and snatch him and they make it look
like they staged a hit
like I did hit him and if the FBI found
him first
in duty reversed you know they'd snatch
him stage your head I couldn't find him
so after like a week I said Sonny I
can't find him he said okay he's not
there anymore
he said we got word he's back in he's
back in New York come on back I go back
to New York we're still looking for him
now during that whole six years I never
carried a gun but now Sonny gives me one
Sonny no because now there's a shoe yeah
of course yeah I mean we
go to a wedding and guys you know but
before on a day-to-day basis wiseguys
don't carry guns the only time they
carry the gun is if they're gonna go do
a piece of work now what's the story
about lefty carrying - because back then
why would you go kill somebody okay when
you go you need to would take - yeah
because the guns were all then it would
give sometimes got it
why don't they carry guns in a daily
basis cause you're always getting
rousted by the cops
hmm why do you need you know sure why do
you need that accent so the only you
know like I would I always get a kick
out of watching gangster movies you see
gangsters were shoulder holsters and you
know where the guns are they're in your
pocket they're in your waist I never saw
a gangster with a whole shoulder any
kind of holster yet so you get the gun
six six years into it gives you the only
time I carried a gun and and the scene
with the boat that scene with the boat
was it pretty vividly close to what the
scene was with the boat with you and a
lefty were you getting close Sony's
there you see him you turn off the
lights then you go in he comes out
you're about to he's about to shoot him
you're not gonna do anything about it
that's Hollywood so that wasn't the case
yeah what happened was we're in the club
one day remember I had the contract to
kill Bruno so when you get a contract in
the mob it's your responsibility that
that guy gets killed now I might not
pull the trigger I can't get somebody to
do the work from but I have to be there
sure engine so Sonny gets call and he
says Bruno's that such that's a place I
gotta get the other guys together so get
our guns okay start to get in a car
phone rings it's bad information he's
not there my problem is if he was there
and we get there what do I do
you're gonna call do I say hey wait a
minute guys I'm an FBI agent we can't
kill him what do you think it's killed
then you right there first of all yeah
Donnie you've been around six years if
we get there I gotta tell you I'm not
dying for a gangster I'll die for you
but you're a citizen your citizens ain't
dying for a gangster
Wow yeah so you are truly like a
real-deal patriot you're not that you
you bleed red white and blue you're
gonna do it for this country you're not
even good Wow
so so let me let me ask you this
question so this whole thing gets done
obviously you know everybody gets killed
at that time a lot of these guys that
you were in business with and friends
with for many years you know you hear
this story about Sonny with the Rolexes
and Lefty with the girl and hey Sonny
says hey tell Jo and the movie I think
they have left he say to his girlfriend
but in real life it's Sonny says it to
his girl that yeah that correction there
at a that story yeah I do
the FBI goes to Sonny left E&M in the
club and what we had done we we took a
picture of me and up other FBI ages
that's Sonny knew from you know from
years of them working him I'm there and
I got my credentials and they go to
Sonny and they say you know this guy in
said well he's he's really Joe Pistone
FBI agent undercover they leave now we
had wires going there talking it's like
there's no way down he's none to
covering no no ways an FBI a did you
actually hear that live yourself that
the wiring of no no no I didn't hear no
because I was in Washington at this time
God their thought process was the FBI
kidnapped Donnie snatched him and our
brain watching them and trying to make
him inform it that Wow that's how good
you were that's that that was there
that's how good you were to get them
yeah once the indict indictments come
out you know and everything now they now
they realize it right
hey it really was an FBI agent so now
Sonny gets a call he gets called to a
sit-down he knows what it is
yeah just talking about gangsters and
remember I said there's gangsters and
gangsters yeah
he goes in the bar takes off his watch
takes off his diamond ring goes in his
pocket takes out his money takes all
this keys but his car keys says it a
bartender
I'm going to a sit-down and I probably
not coming back cause his girlfriend and
says tells her the same thing if you
ever see Donny tell him I loved him and
I'm glad it was him he was just better
than we were he goes in to sit down and
they whack him now he I mean
tells the bartender I'm going to a
sit-down this is sunny and I'm probably
not coming back now they don't find his
body for a year
yeah and when they did they found him
with his right why because he had to be
shaking hands with what boss Wow now
they whacked Mira
because he was the first one that
brought me in Jilly got killed the
Columbo left he's on his way to get
killed and the FBI overheard it on a
wire so they snatched him before he got
to the destination where they were gonna
left him yeah so what happened to lofty
he went to jail
and he died eventually and he did 15 he
had cancer dove penis he had lung cancer
he had oral cancer they took one of his
lungs out in prison and then they found
he had cancer in the other lung and he
had like six months to live or something
not not me six weeks or something to
live so they just released him I said go
die home so he actually died outside of
prison did you ever reunite with never
nothing no call no no indirect
communication we were we were at a trial
in Milwaukee you had like 16 17 trials
that you do you had 17 on that one
Wow that's not counting the other trial
got it so you're on this trial in
Milwaukee and no no no it was a trial in
it was a trial in Tampa he gets up and
tells it a judge he should be in jail
he's on in court Lefty yeah when I
walked in to testify he's how under the
judge that I should be in jail not him
why I was the undercover agent I guess
and then so you could see the hate you
could see oh my god
and then in Milwaukee do US attorney not
the US attorney but the assistant US
attorney comes to me and he says you
think we could turn lefty I said 24/7
gangs not gonna do never in a million
years you told him though he says well
I'm gonna go talk to him
I said here's what's gonna happen you're
gonna walk in there into jail he's gonna
start mother-effing you tell you to get
the F out of here he comes back and he
said how did you know I know the guy
yeah so he died out outside of jail now
the part where it says you get $500 for
your service is that Hollywood is that
true no that's that's what I got okay so
now here's my question for you a sixth
of your life you give up truly it's like
you gave up sixth of your life you've
seen your wife and your three kids once
every four five six months and when you
see them it's one or two days and you're
gone right you miss those memories those
recitals and you finish up and they only
give you five hundred dollars for
putting your life on the line and then
that's it did they give you a retirement
or pension anything else for that was it
now I had to do mic night at the mic
like 20 what I did what you know I did
get the United States Attorney General's
Award that doesn't pay you four grand a
month for the rest your life is now and
and and I got a $5,000 check for that
from the Department of Justice a 5,500
bucks 5,500 bucks private school is more
than that four kids in college right so
was there a part of you where deep down
and said you're like give me a break
I just put my life on the line you give
me only this much I mean because you
know here's why here's why I'm asking
this question your life will never be
the same again never be there well my
kids neither will your kids neither will
your wife or having put up with this
I mean pay for my college kids college
give us $200,000 per kid for college
take care of me give me a place have a
secrets have somebody around me but you
brought out 245 convictions is there any
part of you
kind of saying the system you know you
got to take care of a guy like me if you
want to do this on the next guy that
does it you know you got to make sure
the systems change was there any
animosity towards the way they took
carry at the end there was only one
where I had one boss that was a real
pain in the arse you don't do it for
money you don't work undercover you know
for a reward I get that no but but
listen you know I did have a hard time
from from one si si that's a special
agent charge of it of a field Division
if there was any any why you letting
this guy do this to headquarters but as
far as the FBI as a whole I don't have
any ill feelings you know because most
other than this one guy everybody else
treated me fair
I understand treatment I understand the
treatment part and I know this guy was a
pain in the arse but I'm talking about
return for your time and service you
know you do 20 years in the Army they
give you 50 percent you every time you
do 30 years they give you 75 I don't
know what the numbers right now 75 100
percent six years okay they can't be
given back to you now you think it's
okay that they only gave you 55 on the
rocks honestly I mean I mean there is
the other part that it's kind of like
listen if if I'm if I'm about to be the
next Joe Pistone and I'm about to work
on a case that's for a Russian mob let's
just say and I'm Russian I grew up in
Moscow and I speak the language and I'm
got the swagger because I grew up in a
part in New York or LA that's part of
that and I'm going to get into and I
call you and I say hey Joe listen if you
do me a favor you know I understand you
so I'm about to think about doing this
I'm 30 or so I got a wife and three kids
should I do it what would you tell me no
no seriously see see now now that's why
because you have a wife and three kids
so if you have to do it all over again
you wouldn't do it but I do it would you
do it if you had to do it all over again
I probably lean in yes so there's a
bipolar relationship there that you
would tell me not to do it right because
there's an issue yeah because you're
married and you got three kids but
you're married and three kids I know but
I'm looking out for you so I'm looking
out for you my priest I'm looking out
for your wife your wife is watching and
saying how about you Joe you know you
know my kids had to change schools well
they had to move out of state oh they
had to change their names all the
records because don't forget there was a
contract out on me by the mob five
hundred thousand dollar contract thing
that would have really pay to have
familiar to somebody if they would if
they would have whacked me then you
think so yeah you really believe that
back then yeah yeah yeah now so you feel
safer today now there's when you go oh
yeah okay but the first couple years
because I know they were out looking for
me the first couple years well how long
is a couple years just two years or like
there are 10 years for about the first
three or four years okay hey Opie
because you know from informants you
know the FBI knows what was there
anybody always protecting you or not
really when you were going out pony had
trials at trials I aside from that you
go into your house somebody follows you
were sorry it's your life sign me up you
know what I'm saying a great program -
so it's okay so so to finish this thing
off here do you do you follow on what's
going on if there's still the mobs
around you know it is it completely
depleted cuz you know I interviewed
Michael and all of a sudden I got
messages from we have a big following
from Italy I got a bunch of messages
from Italy and in all of us and I got a
bunch of messages from Sicily and I get
this message from Sicily and here's what
it sounds like he says listen it may not
be Iran as strong as it was in New York
but it's still 100 percent of running in
Sicily and everything in Sicily is ran
by them so do they still have a presence
in New York or is the president still
just all in Italy the strongest presence
of of course is in Sicily and mainland
in the US and I say when I say we I'm
talking about the FBI another look you
know other federal agencies and and I'm
proud to say that our case was a
catalyst because it showed that they
weren't invincible then the FBI brought
all these other cases on the mob today
is just another organized crime group in
the United States when I say to mom talk
about the the American Mafia they're
still in the gambling they're still in
the drugs still still in the extortions
but what they don't have which made them
strong prior to the big push by the FBI
they don't control all the labor unions
like they did hmm they don't have
politicians in their pocket like they
did they don't not not like they did
back in a day they don't have judges in
their pocket like they did they don't
have law enforcement in their pocket
like they did you know back in the day
you controlled the unions you control
politicians you control the whole
country they don't have that anymore
they're basically no stronger than any
other organized crime group in the US
where prior to to us going after them in
the you know in in in the 80s with with
like I said and I'm proud of it that our
case was the the catalyst that showed
they're not invincible I mean you you
have it on multiple different website
where they talk about that the biggest
undercover stories of FBI ever had
multiple multiple multiple articles say
yours is in the top five of the greatest
ever to be able to last as long as you
did you the only one that was in that in
that world with the momma you're the
only guy that was able to do it six
years which is absolutely amazing to me
to hear that did you ever hear from
Giuliani did he ever call you and say
congratulations good - yeah I've heard
him say a few things about Judy was good
Rudy was great you know what would be
interesting you'd be interesting if in
the same room as Joe Pistone Rudy
Giuliani Michael Franzese he and a few
guys and say hey you know to have that
dialogue good conversation it'd be a
great conversation that we can put
together yeah we got a table so the only
person we got to get a hold of is
Giuliana if we get the three of us in
the same room that would be a I'm sure
your producers can do that I think we I
think that maybe
different I think be a great show I
think we great you two kind of go
through because you guys you positively
impacted the safety of a city which is
one of the greatest cities in the world
some basics the greatest city in the
world you positively impact that the
safety of that city that's affected
other people that are wanting to raise
their kids there not have to worry about
it one or forty five convictions it's
fantastic so we're at the end so here's
what I like to do you've written several
books obviously you've been part of a
few different projects the one I know
about is Donnie Brasco Donnie you a Joe
you could obviously sign this and and
and maybe we'll do giveaway will give it
away to some of the guys that can get
that but you got a couple other books
that you bring yes tell us about some of
those projects Donnie Brasco my
undercover life in the Mafia is the
first book and then of course the the
movie or that was a just Donnie Brasco
and then I got a second book called
unfinished business which is a
continuation of my undercover life in
the Mafia because I had other trials to
go through because of this because of
that so unfinished business brings it
together I have another book called the
weight of wiseguy and basically it is
the way the wiseguy how wise guys act
what wise guys do you know how they act
when they go into a restaurant etc
cetera but the two main books about the
cases are my undercover life in a mafia
and unfinished business so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna put the links
below for you to we'll put the links of
all the three books below for you to go
out there and get it for some of you
that you haven't watched Donnie Brasco
first all you got to go brother this
Danny that the movie sends you really
knows and residuals or no did you do you
get anything from the movie or no for
the movie be made of your story no I I
don't because I you know well I I had
about a 30-second scene in the movie now
where I think I said five words so we're
using either with with scene of the boat
I'm gonna let you look at the moon oh my
gosh the boat so if there's if there's a
residual to me it's like you know twelve
dollars or ten dollars because you know
how that works your story and it's your
story yeah unless you unless you're an
actor it's a word yeah did you ever meet
Johnny Depp and Pacino or no there was
no more yeah no I spent a lot of time
with Johnny and I spent a lot of time
without prior you know prepping for the
preppin for Lefty's role and and then I
show him every day on set I was I was on
set every day so every day as a
technical advisor Wow so you were
constantly advised that he wouldn't say
this take this approach say this
interesting experience that but it was
great guys both great so guys go order
his books if you haven't watched Donnie
Brasco will tell you go watch it and you
know I put a tweet the other day and I
asked the question so tell me what are
some of your favorite mafia mobster
movies of all time and I wasn't hinting
that I'm sitting with you today because
you know the sensitivity aspect of it
and then all of a sudden you know
Godfather
Carlito's Way and in Donnie Brasco
Donnie Brasco Donnie Brasco so I asked
so what'd you like about that me
Bharat's good cuz I'm trying to see what
they can you know it's the story of Jai
don't know if you know pattice the
stomach oh I didn't know that you know
it's a now it's it's is I always you
know get calls from different guys in
and some colleges in their criminal
justice courses use that book which one
banning anymore yeah now you don't do a
lot of interviews though when I when I
see you not many know you done some
documentary and go past oh you haven't
seen a lot of stuff you've done the last
10 years yeah well first of all thank
you for taking the time and spending
time here with us your story is as
fascinating as it gets my level of
appreciation for your stories at the
whole different level now that I get a
chance to ask some of this question
thank you but thank you so much thank
you
appreciation no thank you